young students today don't have those  abilities to sit down with you know i  always say sit down with your grandpa  maybe he wasn't ceo or something but  listen to  her stories his stories whatever because  there's a wealth of  information in there they overcame they  were through some  tough times some generations that they  have done some things and  i always find it fascinating when i can  find someone who's older than me  and wants to talk to me i'll just sit  there and listen to when i just  and you never know somebody says where  do you get your ideas  so by listening to people you know  people will say things and they don't  even understand what they said but i'm  the type of individual i'm a great  listener i can hear and i've made a  fortune i'll just listen to people